so the news this morning about more
travel headaches for anyone wanting to
fly out of the country from gatwick or
heathrow this morning gatwick airport
reducing the number of flights over its
summer schedule the boss of heathrow
saying it could take more than a year
year to 18 months to sort this all out
horrendous for anyone wanting to get
away what can be done about it
well i think the first thing is that we
have to ask our airlines why they don't
forward plan
it's not as though people turn up
unannounced to get on a plane they do
book these seats many months in advance
why is it that the airlines have not
been making sure they have sufficient
members of staff and i personally think
that what they've done is they've cut
they've shed people and now they're
having problems getting them back
because many people have and the the
women particularly these largely women
who who check tickets are finding that
they actually
get more money if they work in a local
supermarket than if they trek out to
heathrow and check tickets and so they
don't want to come back so i think that
the airlines have to think carefully
about that and and you know when i've
spoken to airline staff and i have
they've said they can't believe that the
airlines have been so short-sighted have
laid off so many staff and now they
realize they can't get them back but you
can understand
the problem that they've had the
pandemic was a nightmare for them having
to shut down so many services and very
hard for them to predict
exactly how many staff might be
available when they want to restart
things and and give people the chance to
have a holiday yes i get that i get that
argument but i think that it's also been
used by by the likes of british airways
it was a british joey steward as i was
speaking to and she was saying that she
felt the british airways had used the
pandemic as an excuse to shed staff and
they'd shed far too many and now in
crisis but i mean that was what i'm just
repeating in conversation that i had
with with somebody who wanted to talk to
me about about the chaos in the airports
so you put this all on the industry do
you think the government could do
anything about this what would you do
well i think that if i was transport
minister i would be sitting down with
the airlines and saying what is the plan
how are you going to get through this
and what can we do to help you you know
because we need to make sure that we
have a we have a transporter industry
that works properly that are that our
airports work as efficiently as possible
you can't have people waiting for hours
for baggage or indeed people waiting for
hours to get through immigration um or
their flights being cancelled whilst
they're sitting in the airport it's not
good enough so yes i think that it's
right for the minister to bring people
in and challenge them and find out how
they're going to ensure that this
doesn't happen people sacrifice in order
to save enough money to be able to go on
holiday with their family and for that
holiday to be cancelled at the last
minute is simply not acceptable in this
day and age you say you want a transport
system that works what about the rail
system we're facing huge strikes next
week three days of strikes but a whole
week of disruption
do you back the strikers
i think that what they should be doing
is they should be sitting down with the
employers and with government and
discussing
how they're going to get through this we
have very low paid cleaners for example
on the trains who are finding it very
difficult to meet their bills now that
will happen up and down the country in
all sorts of different industries in the
near future because of the cost of
living crisis because of inflation so we
need to make sure that we are not
encouraging strikes we are encouraging
people to talk and and what we have is a
government that is standing back and
saying we're not talking to anybody we
want to just point the finger at labor
and blame labor as if it's our fault not
not encouraging strikes but supporting
strikers do you support those who are
going to walk out next week i don't want
them to walk out next week but no no one
wants them to know that that's why you
know so i'm not supporting them to walk
out next week i want you to attack them
he takes two no no no no no i think that
it takes two to tango what we need is we
need the unions and the employers with
government because it's you know very
important than the amount of government
money that goes into our our rail
industry we need those them to sit down
and actually think about how they are
going to probably said that so would you
say to those strikers do not go on
strike i would say that any strike is a
failure what we need to be doing is we
need to be able to find a way through it
together and we need to set that as a
precedent because this is going to be a
crisis that will apply to many
industries in the near future and
responsible government would be involved
i mean you know one here is that they
are bragging about the fact they haven't
spoken to the union since march why not
but it feels like you don't want to take
a tough position on this i mean normally
wouldn't a labour party be very happy to
to stand up for strikers and say we back
them in taking this action
we want to make sure that we have a
transport system that works properly it
does not work properly when relations
have broken down so much that people are
threatening to go on strike we need to
make sure that our rail industry works
properly and we cannot have a government
that simply thinks that their job is to
score political points they need to be
in the weeds with the employers and the
unions and the workers and say how are
we going to deal with this how are we
given that it's going to be 11 inflation
how do we make sure that you know the
lady who who cleans the the carriages
lose you know is getting paid properly
so that she can meet her bills
it sounds like you want to put this all
on the government but but
i i'm interested to know why you won't
stick your neck out on a position on on
backing the strikers or not is the
labour party just scared of offending
some sections of society no i'm taking
an overview so during the pandemic
because so many of the railways were
dependent obviously on the fairs and
people weren't traveling on the trains
it means that many of the railway
companies
are don't have sufficient income they
are using that much as i was saying
about british airways you know i think
that they are they're over steering in
the wrong direction they're trying to
cut back on routes they're trying to cut
back on employees and they're not
prepared to increase wages that then
means that you have to take a strategic
view of this which is what the job of
government is the government should be
taking a strategic view of what is what
is best for all of us when it comes to
our railway system and not spending time
having a pop at the labour party okay
let's move on to the economy you
mentioned 11 inflation looming as the
bank of england pointed out yesterday
so people are facing an unprecedented
cost of living squeeze what can be done
about it
we think that there are a number of
things that can be done and we've we've
obviously we talked about the um the the
levy that has that has happened the
windfall tax um uh on on energy energy
companies i mean the government and the
government has started to do that and
it's it's committed to going further
than new suggestions yeah although it
doesn't really
there are all kinds of technical
problems with it i mean for example you
know if someone was to own four homes um
then they would get they would get that
lump sum you know in every single home
that they had i mean these sorts of
things are a problem um there are there
are a number of problems with it and and
it's a shame they hadn't really thought
this through and it's a shame they
hadn't they hadn't um was more than a
shame that they hadn't uh
directed their minds to it much earlier
you know when we started to call for it
at the beginning of the year but there
are other things that can be done so
just like there's uh the the energy
companies have had a windfall in terms
of their profits because the price is
going up the government has had a
windfall when it comes to vat so the
government gets a 5 vat on energy on on
the gas bills and the electric bills we
would say that you should cut the
government should be cutting v80 and
that would also help with the prices of
people's bills they haven't done that
it's one of the things that we've been
calling for now for i think probably six
months so i mean i think we think that
would be the sort of thing the the cut
to um benefits the 20 pounds a week cut
that the government have made to
universal credit we think is wrong and
they should stop that we think that they
should be they should not be introducing
the increase in national insurance which
is a tax on jobs so here is a number of
things that the government should still
be doing and they're not okay i want
your thoughts on a couple more things we
don't have very much time with you um we
got the resignation letter yesterday of
the prime minister's ethics advisor lord
a guide
what did you make of it
well i thought it was
poor lord getting to the end of his
tether i mean what a job you know the
idea of your job being to keep boris
johnson honest i mean
it's just like it's a job from hell and
he'd waited i think they looked for five
months to find someone who's prepared to
step up and he had to appear in front of
a select committee he had to defend
boris johnson publicly i mean it's
humiliating so of course he wanted to go
and i my heart goes out to the poor man
i don't know who they're going to get to
replace him because you know that we
have a government who is committed as
far as i can see to pushing things as
much as they can seeing what they can
get away with and believing themselves
to be above the law so what do you think
should happen to the role do you think
it should change at all should it be we
should be decided by mps generally in
parliament and an independent what do
you think should happen i don't think
this is going to get fixed by having a
new ethics advisor i think the only way
that we're going to get number 10 honest
is to get a new prime minister
well
no big surprise for labor to call for a
different prime minister
but it comes but the culture comes from
the top when you have a prime minister
who thinks it's fine to do whatever you
like and somehow or other rules don't
apply to them you then get ministers who
start aping it ministers who think that
they can behave in this way as well keep
pushing things along that's what they're
doing that's what this government is
about you know but it shouldn't be like
that we're a democracy the law is
important you should not be just
thinking you can do whatever you like
and somehow or other it'll be fine and
um we should talk about what you wanted
to talk about today there's so many
other issues that i i did want to put to
you uh which were of great interest to
everybody but you have written a letter
to boris johnson today about support for
rape survivors tell us what you're
asking
along with 98 um labor women mps we're
really worried about the changes that
are being proposed to
what can be disclosed to the defendant
in a rape case and they're watering down
the rules as far as we can see on the
rules on whether or not um if a woman
goes to get therapy and there are notes
made we're really worried that they're
making it easier for those notes to be
disclosed to the defendant and given
that only like 1.5 percent of rapes
actually end up going to court all the
way you know we can do without it being
more difficult and many women will
essentially be face the choice of do you
want to support the criminal justice
system do you want to see the guy being
brought to justice or do you want to
look after your mental health